hey guys Pete here I had a lot of
question about Arya Starks dire wolf
Nymeria in the comments on my dire wolf
Theory video so today I decided to put
together everything we know about Aria's
wolf Nymeria and whether or not we might
see them together again the show Game of
Thrones hasn't really brought the dire
wolf up since we saw her in Arya part
ways but we know a lot from the book so
let's jump right into it oh and don't
forget to stay tuned in to the end of
the video to learn about the giveaway I
have going on right now we don't
remember that each of the stark children
were given a dire wolf pup after their
mother was found dead south of the wall
Ned's initial thought was to kill them
since they weren't likely to survive
without their mother but Jon Snow
pointed out that the number of pups
match the number of Ned and Catelyn
Strube own children which was likely a
sign that they should raise them given
that House Stark sigil is a direwolf Ned
relents and at the end John finds one
more pup which was the brunt and he
keeps that one for him so from that
point on they raise the pups who grow to
go with them pretty much everywhere they
go the one exception is shaggy dog who
belongs to Rickon he's kind of
aggressive and bites a few people at
Winterfell and that combined with the
fact that Rickon is too young to control
him sees him tied up most of the time
other than that the children in the
diary will have spent most of their time
together as companions so when Sansa and
Arya go south to King's Landing with
their father and the king they take
their wolves with them and the
Riverlands Prince Joffrey and Sansa find
Arya and her friend Micah by the Trident
River Joffrey challenges Micah to a duel
and ends up cutting him and it causes a
big problem Joffrey won't stop so Arya
hits him with her stick Joffrey attacks
Arya with his sword and Nymeria lunges a
Joffrey to protect her and bites him
after letting him go arya Nymeria flee
and from there we get this classic scene
from the show
you've got to go they'll kill you for
you that's Jeffrey go on run go leave
No
so the direwolf paid the price of having
to be separated from Aria who we know
actually saved my Maria's life by doing
this there's no doubt that Cersei would
have had Nymeria put down since she has
Sansa's wolf lady killed in her place
that is the last time we seen a Marian
in the show in the books we get to check
in with Nymeria every so often through
arias wolf dreams where she sees through
her former pet sighs in these dreams she
leads a pack a man eating regular wolves
around Westeros if you haven't read the
books the idea of wolf Dreams might be
foreign since they are largely left out
of the show in the show we see bran
Morgan does wolf summer but in the books
we know that all the stark children who
have point-of-view chapters enter their
dire wolves through dreams a lot of
important things happen in these dreams
including the Starks sensing each other
through them in fact it's night Miria
via arias dream that pulls the dead body
of Catelyn Stark out of the river by now
Nymeria was tiring and it was all she
could do to pull the body back to shore
now she dragged it up the muddy Bank one
of her little brothers came prowling his
tongue lolling from his mouth she had to
snarl to drive him off or else he would
have fed only then did she stop to shake
the water from her fur the white thing
lay facedown in the mud her dead flesh
wrinkled in pale cold blood trickling
from her throat ra's she thought rise
and eat and run with us after that the
Brotherhood without banners comes along
in the Wolves leave and then a bunch of
other stuff happens but it's really not
important for this video and I don't
really want to go all the way down that
road right now but now that Aria is back
in Westeros on the show and the Starks
have retaken Winterfell it's possible we
could see a reunion for a girl and her
dog actually happened there are plenty
of mentions of the super pack which is
led by a huge female that isn't afraid
of men who just happens to be in the
Riverlands where we last saw a knight
Miriah there's actually a reference to a
sighting of Numa area or the pack in
every single book so I would say it's
just a matter of time until we hear more
about her there will probably be a
reunion but we have to cross our fingers
that we'll actually see that in the show
though he's only probably talking about
the books george RR martin actually
spilled in 2014 that we haven't seen the
laughs in Nymeria and her
I'll pass he said you know I don't like
to give things away but you don't hang a
giant wolf back on the wall unless you
intend to use it so giant wolf pack with
Nymeria as the alpha female is confirmed
but what happens with it and if we see
even see that part in the show is purely
speculation if you're wondering where
aria got the name for Nymeria since it
is the most unique of all the direwolf
names she's named after a warrior
princess when the Bleriot freehold
conquered the Rhoyne with their dragons
nummy rhea was a leader who led the
surviving Rhoyne art into exile from
Essos
the warrior queen then brought 10,000
ships across the Narrow Sea to the
shores of Dorne in southern Westeros she
struck an alliance with house Martell of
Sunspear taking Lord Mors Martell as her
husband and burning the Rhoyne art fleet
the Martell Rhoyne our alliance
conquered the rest of Dorne and Nymeria
sent the six defeated Dornish Kings to
join the Nights Watch Nami Ria's life
inspired the books 10,000 ships in the
luvs of Queen Nymeria and this is how
Arya would have been familiar with the
story and the name the last two
encounters with Nymeria in the books are
both from a dance with dragon in John's
first point of view chapter he
encounters Nymeria in a dream as he's in
ghost he sees Knight Marius singing
under the moon and a hundred little
great cousins of her pack singing with
her she was in the hills which were
warmer than the wall and full of food so
her pack is you know according to this
dream pretty large later in the same
book when Ahri is training with the
faceless man in Braavos and his blind
she slips into Nymeria and a wolf's
dream during that dream she sees the
night sky in Westeros and the first
snowfall in the Riverland it's
interesting in her journey to become
no.1 that her connection with Nymeria
often reminds her of home and who she
actually is and you have to remember
that we know that Arya was really close
with Nymeria you know she had her with
her all the time and was fiercely
protective of her so that's the story of
where Arya's direwolf Nymeria went after
we saw her being chased away let me know
what you guys think in the comments do
you think Aria and Nymeria will be
reunited in the winds of winter do you
think that the main reason we don't get
to see very much direwolf action
the show is because of the CGI cost and
if that's the case do you think that
this means that we will never see the
two of them back together in the actual
show Game of Thrones please like the
video and subscribe to my channel for a
chance to win a copy of the night of the
Seven Kingdoms I'm doing a giveaway for
when I hit 18,000 subscribers all you
have to do is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video it only takes a
second and you might win you also have a
chance to catch all my latest game of
Thrones related videos as soon as they
come out thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon